brian kelly author of adventures in
portland what's the difference between
the gas congress and the money congress
gasps Congress are the talkers gasps
Congress are the guys who take up so
much of this time on c-span talking
about some things that are important
some things or not but they're public
that the guys who'd like to be out front
the money Congress are the guys who
would prefer to be behind closed doors
and their business is spending the money
writing the bills and sometimes keeping
a little bit for themselves name a
couple people from the gas Congress well
I like Bob Dole one of my favorites I
suppose phil gramm always always out
front was something Ted Kennedy Al Gore
in his day at least had gone beyond that
I suppose r is the gas Congress at all
interested and the money Congress
certainly there's some intersections I
think anybody who can get into the money
Congress would love to would love to be
there but I think you do have some
people who Capitol Hill with very
different intentions some people come up
here more for the public policy side of
things whether it's ego or genuine
interest money in on Capitol Hill seems
to me to be a very specific discipline
these are people who are dedicated to
for good or bad they are dedicated to
that business who are some of the money
Congress well Bob Byrd of course the top
of the list but some of the more obscure
folks like Jamie Witten John Murtha from
Pennsylvania Joe mcdade mark Hatfield I
guess guy who maybe isn't got 11 foot in
both sides of it al d'amato guy with a
pretty good understanding of the way
money works but also not not too shy in
front of a TV camera but then you can
work down the list particularly the
house appropriations committee that the
College of Cardinals subcommittee
chairman people like bill Laymon for
instance or Neil Smith from Iowa most
people have rarely if ever seen these
guys unless maybe they put him in office
how do they get to be a member of the
College of Cardinals how many are there
by the way in that group well the the
college is the appropriations committees
in the House and Senate so you've got
the 13 subcommittee chairman the
and the the ranking Republican sometimes
are considered honorary members
depending depending on their how
friendly they are with with the Chairman
I suppose to like any of the committee's
I mean one of the most sought-after
committee certainly on Capitol Hill
these are people who Lobby hard for
these jobs seniority obviously plays a
very key role in this but not not the
only role and once they take these
positions the reason they call in the
College of Cardinals I guess really a
term of kind of fear and respect because
of the prominence that they exercised
over the process when if you are the
chairman of the agriculture subcommittee
and the Appropriations Committee in the
house as Jamie Witten is here you know
they call him the Permanent Secretary of
Agriculture these are the guys who
really control that function of
government somewhere in your book you
say that the USS Kennedy and its
relationship to the Philadelphia Naval
Shipyard is the seven hundred dollar 700
million dollar toilet see what are you
talking about the I tell the story in
there of the Philadelphia shipyard and
the Kennedy which which happened a year
ago in the spring and this was the a
classic case of pork barrelling a
classic case of what was the
Supplemental appropriations bill the
dire emergency supplemental
appropriations bill after Desert Storm
the idea was we had had this major
military Emergency we had some extra
bills we were going to have to pay some
of these bills well among the other
things that ended up in that bill as
they often do was a line to which said
that Congress would have to rehab the
USS Kennedy the nuclear aircraft carrier
that's all it said simple line inserted
in the Bill Kennedy had nothing to do
with Desert Storm there was no emergency
here but it was in the bill what it
turned out to be was the only place the
Kennedy could be rehabbed was the
Philadelphia Naval Shipyard which was
scheduled to be closed if you forced
Congress to rehab the Kennedy you
therefore had to do it at the
Philadelphia Naval Shipyard the Pentagon
didn't want this done they wanted to
close the shipyard they didn't want to
rehab the Kennedy but
once you put those pieces together you
were going to cause the taxpayers to pay
an extra seven hundred million dollars
to rehab the ship to keep open the
Philadelphia Naval Yard against the
Pentagon's wishes thus the 700 billion
dollar toilet see how did what happen to
it a classic case of tactics on the
floor as well dan coats from Indiana
spied this item in the bill it's often
hard to find this pork as it's moving
down the track it moves pretty fast and
whips out of the committee's very
rapidly but here was a case where he
knew it was coming saw it raised a stink
on the floor made a made a very
impassioned argument to his fellow
senators that this had no business going
through it was a classic pork barrel
project they were trying to save that
the telegin from pennsylvania was trying
to save the shipyard he said you know
let's let's show some courage here let's
step up and say this is spending that we
don't need that's a speech that's
delivered many times and Senate in the
house increasingly I suppose remarkably
though his fellows agreed with them when
they cast the vote much to the surprise
of a lot of people on the Senate floor
the motion passed the amendment to
strike this out was approved the way the
process works of course the next day
there's a conference committee the house
had kept the item in in literally this
was midnight I mean sometimes it's too
good to be true but literally at the
stroke of midnight in a conference
committee behind closed doors the item
was simply written back into the bill
John Murtha from Pennsylvania and Joe
mcdade from Pennsylvania both sat on
that conference committee they were
intent on keeping it in there Dan in a
way and Ted Stevens were the ranking
Senate members on defense appropriations
they had no particular interest in
fighting this issue the item got put
back in the next day Friday the day
before the Easter recess dan coats
finally at the last minute discovers
that in fact it has been put back in
literally can't find the people who
voted with him in the first place
they've all gone for vacation left for
recess or in some cases they said well
come on Dan you know we gave you your
vote but
there's no way that we're really going
to fight this thing to the death and
sailed through was signed into law and
at this point we're getting ready to
rehab the Kennedy for seven hundred
million dollars more than the Pentagon
wants to spend at the Philadelphia Naval
healthy Naval Shipyard was that but
wasn't the Philadelphia Naval Shipyard a
part of that shutdown well it was on the
base closing Commission list but part of
what they're trying to do with the
Kennedy is of course the yard won't the
at the very least the yard won't be
closed down until the Kennedy project is
completed so they've bought themselves
another three or four years of staying
open even even if it maintains its
position on that list and they do
actually intend to close it the Kennedy
doesn't need to be rehabbed Pentagon
says no they were they were going to do
some minor work on it to bring it up to
a serviceable status although it's a
ship that they were prepared to mothball
fairly soon so chain egan that runs this
ship says it does not need to be
rehabilitated rebuilt and the Congress
has put money and it says it's got to be
exactly how often does that happen often
particularly in the area of Defense
people like Bertha McDade in a way
Stevens people who exercise tremendous
influence over the defense budget view
themselves as a mini Pentagon they they
make decisions which theoretically
affect national security they will often
say these are decisions based on
national security concerns when in fact
there's always an explanation a little
more parochial than that the National
Guard being a great case in point
Bertha's has has staked out his role as
the defender of the National Guard we
are cutting back vastly in military
projects across the country
reducing the size of the forces
enormously yet the National Guard
maintains its strength principally
because John Martha says this is this is
the way it has to be I'm going to keep
the National Guard at full strength you
say that the one of the efforts on the
part of Congress of Martha is to get a
private plane for each National Guard
commander for each state right he has
been working on this for a number of
years he's buying these sort of things
sophisticated executive type jets as I
don't know quite how far along he is at
this point I mean he's run into some
trouble on that let in the last year but
had been setting out to to have the
Pentagon by these planes and offer them
for the use of the National Guard
commanders in the history of this
network after lots and lots of requests
John Murtha has never been in the studio
never done a call and she'll never done
an interview can you tell you haven't he
can you give us any background why he's
not doesn't talk to the national media
well I'm not surprised to hear that and
and that is the the method of operation
of so many of these folks in the money
Congress their attitude is that national
publicity does them no good they exist
in a completely parochial realm their
idea is what can I get for the folks
back home for my constituents whether
it's the actual voters back there
whether it's certain special interests
or in the case of some of these guys
it's a it's a national constituency of
special interests but in any event it
does them no good to talk to the general
public about what it is that they're up
to do this is the classic case of
congressmen who you know will refuse to
be interviewed on on the subject of some
bill that's passed you know being well
they go back to their offices and busily
put together a press release saying you
know to the folks back home here are the
10 things that I just got for you they
give it to the local media they never
give it to the Washington Post or the
New York Times you hold this up and ask
you about this cover right under your
name down here you say this is
illustrated by Pat Oliphant and you've
got the pig with a saber in his hand or
her hand carving knife carving that
excuse me go right up to the top of the
dome of the capitol and you have another
little pig up here then you have this
sub head
Washington waste your money and why they
won't stop are you saying this will
never stop now I'm not saying it will
never stop they won't stop right now
unless somebody makes them stop
ultimately I think a lot of this comes
back to the voters I'm not one of those
people who will buy the argument made on
Capitol Hill that we're just doing what
the voters want us to do that's why
we're bringing home all this pork that's
why we're doing all of this spending I
think that we could see a lot more
political courage being exercised on
Capitol Hill and we'd all be better off
for it but at the same time I think that
people in this country if they
understood what a lot of this spending
was about if they understood pork if
they understood that it wasn't a free
lunch that it wasn't a necessary part of
the process as some people will argue
that it is I think they'd get mad about
this I think they would get increasingly
active in the process as we've seen with
ross perot a lot of the Perot voters
were very much about people getting
energized and angry about spending I
think they would let people on Capitol
Hill hear about this and say stop trying
to buy me a free lunch or hand me a free
lunch when I know it's not free start
spending this money as if it were your
money start spending with the idea that
if you don't have it you can't spend it
which is a theory which is completely
gone to hell in Washington and I think
we would see a response i think we have
seen evidence in the last few months
that the tide of spending can flow both
ways we've seen evidence of some things
happening to cut out spending and we've
also seen misspending come back in so no
I don't think it's hopeless at all but I
don't think it's it's an easily solved
problem want to hold this up so the
camera can get a shot of it actually
that it's turned on its side and I'll
turn it the other way this is a postcard
same thing as the cover of the book and
I'm going to drop it so that I can read
it but it says the Coast Guard a message
to Congress from a reader of adventures
in Portland I have just read adventures
in pork plan by brian kelly an
eye-opening report on the miss making of
the
national budget and I'm alarmed and
angered by the incredible amount of
waste that goes into the budget of this
country as a concerned citizen demanding
that you an elected official do
everything in your power to stop this
abuse and put the money where it is
really needed and you have the i found
this card and the in the book itself
does just come with all the book it does
yeah that was the my publisher is lard
books a part of random house and they
had the idea that let's put our money
where our mouth is you know we're saying
to people get get involved here be heard
get get the message out and they said
well you know we'll spend a few bucks
and put a postcard in here and we'll
give people an opportunity to do it not
that I'm expecting millions of these
postcards to descend on Capitol Hill
although I love it but any evidence that
any of them have been sent yet oh yeah
I've heard from from a few members up
there told me they've gotten some cards
and you know I'm hopeful that you know
the books been out a few weeks now and
I'm hopeful it to it will get more of a
hearing on this and people will respond
to this they don't have to send that
postcard and they can send her own
postcard and they can pick up the phone
on the point we're trying to make is get
activated here get involved in this
process understand what it's about
understand spending people have to start
to look at spending questions a lot more
seriously the average voter has to
educate himself on this it's not magical
it's not you know like trying to learn
trigonometry in grammar school you know
that there's people can learn this I
always make the analogy with the nuclear
arms race a few years ago this was this
incredibly complicated world of mega
tonnage and mutually assured destruction
a lot of people got themselves educated
on that subject and they said this is
wrong we've got to stop this we've got
to put our own voices out there and see
if we can effect some change and they
did people got very educated on nuclear
weapons well that problem is largely
diminished now I think the nuclear
weapons of the 90s are going to be the
whole budget mess and I think the more
people can understand that the more they
can engage themselves in the process and
be heard the better it's going to be for
all of us when did you first get the
idea of this
I was reading a story in The Washington
Post about the Lawrence Welk museum was
in 1990 in the fall of 90 after the
budget compromise some would say the
budget fiasco government had shut down
Bush raised taxes I think there was
genuine concerns that the system had
really spun out of control where were
you then well I was then the editor of
regard ease magazine here in Washington
what's regard ease regard ease is a
magazine and monthly magazine of
business and politics circulating in the
Washington area I'd been the editor
there since about nineteen eighty-five
could it be categorized as irreverent I
think it might be a fair
characterization sure we've we have
always tried to do some stories about
the way Washington works with a certain
attitude attached to them we were
nonpartisan but we tend to poke fun at
either side when we when we see the
opportunities sure why did you leave
there and when did you leave it ah i
left for guard easier this year the
magazine had what has fallen on some
fairly hard financial times and has gone
to a bi-monthly schedule and has really
scaled back considerably and i joined
the washington post as an editor there
earlier this year what would he do at
the post I'm the political editor of the
Style section so we do the longer take
outs the profiles and things about
Washington characters candidates
whatever and where are you from
originally born in New Jersey went to
school here in Washington Georgetown
University started my career in
journalism in chicago i work for the
sun-times out there as a political
writer covering chicago the city the
craziness out there politics has kind of
covered like sports out there it's it's
a contact contact sport work for the
Tribune briefly and then freelance
worked on a few other books and came out
here to work for regard he's really 1985
and what was the thing that greeted to
regard is it just a fascinating
opportunity I think to get into the
Washington
Washington journalism world it was a it
was as you say in a reverent magazine it
was a in its in its day I guess we had
you know huge issues to 300 pages we had
a lot of available we were able to
attract some really good writers and had
a very open franchise in Washington we
didn't have to cover anything we didn't
have to be the post or the times and it
allowed us the opportunity to do some
longer pieces take some longer looks at
at people and events in this town and
have some fun with it so it was just a
great kind of chance to did is it safe
to assume that at some point while
you're there you beat up on the
Washington Post well I'm sure the post
came in for a barb or two yeah we were
we were absolutely nondenominational
there were times when we thought the
post was up to some silliness and we
didn't hesitate to let them know about
it did that hurt you when you went
looking for a job ah no one ever
mentioned well I suppose a few people
mention it they kind of nodded and
smiled and said gee what are you doing
here but they were pretty good about it
it's a big place and they seem to be
able to accept criticism reasonably well
paid job actually 80 62 and it's the
chapter baffle gag and darman land
what's that baffle gabby's an okay I'm
sorry now is a phrase from from Alice in
Wonderland which is where I borrowed the
title um it struck me as I serve move my
way through the money Congress that this
really was a strange world of odd
language and indecipherable doings
darman being a great case in point
Bush's budget director who I write about
it quite great length in the book and I
suppose somewhat critically baffle gabon
dorman land was was when I first
encountered darman talking about the
budget and why we were had this enormous
deficit problem but it wasn't really a
deficit
the problem was actually solving itself
and we didn't need to worry about it
because of the charts and the lines and
it was a press conference where he
brought out all of these bar graphs and
flowcharts and gave this just amazing
performance that left me feeling like I
had been you know had my pocket picked
and it was at that point that I I sort
of thought to myself you know I there's
that there's an unreal quality to all
this the average person watching this
can't possibly be making any sense out
of this and it was one of the things
that I set out to do was to try to make
some sense out of the whole question of
the deficit and the way money is spent
here and the notion of baffle gab just
just stuck in my mind as the only way to
really explain it let me read a little
bit said Richard darman must have been a
happy man that morning in early februari
1991 as he shaved and dressed in his
spectacular home on a five acre lot
overlooking the Potomac in Virginia he
knew he'd be holding center stage in a
few hours doing what he liked best
perhaps he took a little more time to
craft his appearance his appearance of
carelessness let me just read a little
more cuz I want to ask you direct
question as he drove down the George
Washington Parkway to his office next to
the White House that frosty morning the
Sun rose behind the Capitol dome and
cast a soft pink light on the ranks of
pale limestone buildings were you with
him no I was I was not I knew he drove
to work and I had in fact driven it at
the same time so I took a little
literary license and I've qualified it I
said I'm assuming this is what he saw
but it it was a it was a this was the
press conference when he revealed the
budget and it was it was it I was there
watching the whole show the reason i ask
because i just couldn't figure whether
you'd actually you know sat we got into
that LARM and wrote down that George
Washington Parkway and sometimes you
have I think you have to take a little
Lou I I didn't want this to be a
textbook you know i mean it deals with
some serious subjects but i wanted to at
least give people a little of the flavor
of the characters and how they lived
it's all it's all been reported but some
of it not firsthand you also talk about
the budget summit at Andrews Air Force
Base
and some of this same chapters along
here and you write up what I know I made
notes in the margin about the speech of
Bob Byrd right at that event right now
that was all behind closed doors right
right all off the record detective Lee
when is there was no press there right
you almost you write up that speech word
for word right about what he said behind
closed doors right about everything from
alex de tocqueville to other the
Philistines and on and on how did you
get that well turns out that bird gave
the same speech he was so happy with
himself he gave the same speech on the
floor of Congress and it was in a
congressional record and I checked with
his staff people and they confirmed in
fact that it was the it was the same
talk that he had given and then
interviewed a number of other people who
had been in the room and check back the
the substance of it fortunately in Birds
case he gives the same speech many times
he has a particular version of events
that he that he offers as to why we need
all of this spending and it's it is it's
not it's often not new phrasing by the
way before we go in further what is pork
barrel politics where's the word pork
barrel come from pork barrel goes back
to the early 19th century um the
tradition was really in during the days
of slavery the plantation owners would
bring a big barrel filled with pieces of
salt pork out to the field at lunch time
and the slaves would rush the pork
barrel to grab the lunch the biggest
pieces they could get their hands on and
someone made a journalist lost to
history once made the analogy that
watching congressman grab federal
dollars for local projects was like
watching slaves rush the pork barrel and
it since then 150 years ago the phrase
has been one of those great great words
of Capitol Hill like cloture and log
rolling and gerrymandering anybody
confronts you from Capitol Hill saying
this is a this book was a bad idea
no not yet it's early i suppose anybody
mad at you for the book um none that
I've heard of and it is the point you
make about a lot of these guys keeping a
pretty low profile I guess it doesn't
surprise me the pork barrelling is
almost the dirty little secret on
Capitol Hill the folks who do it will
justify it with a variety of reasons
they'll claim that it's necessary
federal spending they'll claim that it's
part of the process they'll claim that
Congress is an imperfect system and this
is the way they smooth out the wrinkles
but almost none of them will talk about
it publicly I made numerous attempts to
interview a lot of the people in here
found it very difficult often i would
get staffers to talk off the record the
Appropriations Committee has really run
like a secret society almost I think one
of the great outrages of this you know
this is one of the absolute most
powerful institutions in the government
yet they feel absolutely no reason no
necessity at all to make any of their
actions public or discuss publicly what
it is that they do Bob Byrd being a
great case in point Bob Byrd is arrogant
enough to feel that he has no need to
deal with the national media at all he
will occasionally talk to a local West
Virginia reporter to crow about the
latest thing that he's brought back home
but here's a man who thinks of himself
as a statesman yet you know behaves like
a petty Ward politician you sound like
though when you read the book that you
have a sometimes admiration for bob burg
well I I do I mean I find bird to be a
fascinating figure absolutely
complicated you know American original
and I spent a great deal of time looking
at bird in his background I traveled
back to his his hometown in fact I found
the little tiny coal hollow that he grew
up in and it's a great a ratio Alger
story started in this little little sum
of a town along the railroad tracks in
coal mining country and that in the
depths of West Virginia and picked
himself up by his bootstraps literally
the cliche is true
educated himself his brilliant man got
himself to Capitol Hill dove the most
Pat one of the most powerful positions i
would argue maybe the most powerful man
on Capitol Hill right now along the way
I think bird may have lost some of the
idealism that might have fueled him in
the first place I mean this is a man who
said Abraham Lincoln out as his model a
man who accumulated all the tools of
power on Capitol Hill he knows how that
place works probably better than anyone
certainly better than anyone today maybe
as well as anyone ever bird knows how to
get things done but to what end does he
use his power to grabbing off a couple
of train loads of goodies to bring back
to West Virginia it just it's it is this
I think a political tragedy in many
senses I think there's a lot to like
about bird a lot of things a lot of
admirable qualities but at the same time
when you look at a man you know at a
time when we need leaders what do we get
out of the most powerful man on Capitol
Hill petty politics let me speak for I
say I sitting out there in West Virginia
watching this and hear you say that and
my reaction is Bob Byrd has brought the
money right back here to this state
that's why we send him to Washington and
when we speak of money what are some of
the things that he's brought back there
well bird has brought just enormous
numbers highways that's been one of his
big initiatives Bob four-lane highways
and towns and obscure areas of West
Virginia that don't even have traffic
lights he has brought huge chunks of the
federal government to West Virginia
forced agencies to relocate throughout
the state he is he has built the
national federal wildlife service as
he's building a giant new training
facility in Harpers Ferry complete with
a aquarium a new national aquarium which
of course is an hour away from the Old
National Aquarium in Baltimore not the
old one the perfectly good National
Aquarium in Baltimore he's a West
Virginia has a declining veterans
population bird is
building new Veterans Hospitals in West
Virginia he took federal HUD low-income
housing dollars to rehab a movie theater
in Huntington West Virginia sort of an
endless list of which has been toted up
i taught up in the book it's more than a
billion dollars of projects and love and
beyond in in the in the first two years
as appropriations chairman he's gotten
about a billion and is a well into the
second billion at this point again if i
were a West Virginia when I say that's
fabulous you would say that which is the
core of the problem i would argue the
core of the spending problem here what
daddy what that represents is the
politics of greed it represents the
attitude that my congressman is a bagman
he's not he's not a national
representative his job is to go to
Washington and grabbed all the goodies
he can get and that makes a certain
logical sense it's human nature I think
it's you know it's wasteful as we see
and and it's not free as I also
explained in the book people think this
is great i'm getting this for nothing i
got a wonderful phone call from a guy
from West Virginia the other day said
you know the new bridge not too far from
where i ambered got this thing he said
now look at it and i was thinking to
myself you know bird got this bridge but
the economies such a wreck i can't
afford a car to drive over it and that i
think is what happens with pork you have
a lot of petty projects that add up the
philosophy is the same behind a lot of
big projects all of them get heaped on
the federal budget deficit which i think
economists have universally concluded is
dragging the economy severely right now
we we are not getting these for free the
people in West Virginia are paying tax
dollars for the projects Bob bird gets
and they're paying for the projects bob
burg gives out they're paying for the
Red River waterway in Louisiana they're
paying for al de Matos hyper expensive
subway system in Buffalo New York
they're paying for all those things
would you say about the subway system
the cost of it 47 to sixty-seven dollars
a passenger for the Buffalo subway
system and ice the thought occurred to
me it would be cheaper to pick people up
with limousines and take them to work
than it would
put them on that subway system he's a
Republican tomorrow is a Republican
right how does he get that kind of clout
as a Republican on these committees to
get a buffalo subway pork is remarkably
bipartisan and it also extends down
Pennsylvania Avenue to the White House
bush we might mention is a pretty big
pork barrel or himself but in in the
appropriations committees I was always
amazed to see the these fellows who
would be red-faced and screaming at each
other when they were appearing on the
floor of the House or Senate over one
issue or another we're just as yummy as
could be when it came to carving up the
pie D'Amato was the ranking Republican
of the transportation subcommittee in
the Senate he is an ally of frank
Lautenberg who's the ranking Democrat of
that committee right over in New Jersey
when the transportation funds get caught
up you will often find the case of bird
usually gets the most because he loves
Road dollars number two will be
Lautenberg number three will be dimana
that's the way the deals are cut
everyone supports the bill everyone
signs on there's no dissent as you work
your way down the food chain the people
who are cooperative with these guys
where the Republicans or Democrats get a
little bit when you get down to the
bottom there's crumbs and the guys like
Bob Smith from New Hampshire who oppose
these projects get nothing what happens
to Bob Smith when he opposes these
project uh how does he opposed a moment
well I tell a classic story in there
last fall transportation appropriations
bill is moving through again as always
rapidly huge complicated bill you think
people spending twenty billion dollars
you think people might take a little
time to study this but they don't the
appropriators keep it close to the vest
as long as they can on Monday Smith
finds that the bill is out and examines
it and realizes that in one particular
category of road fund spending about
five hundred million dollars the
allocation is made up exactly as I say
bird gets half of the five hundred
million dollars for West Virginia
Lautenberg gets a substantial chunk the
motto gets a substantial chunk a few
other people get pieces of it but most
most people most states
nothing out of this particular fund
which was typical of other funds
throughout the bill so he makes it a
judgment I'm going to pose this i'm
going to say what if we took the Highway
Trust Fund formula this has worked out
how we spend the highway trust fund
dollars you have a year estate with X
number of miles of road a federal
highway you pay a certain amount of tax
dollars as a complicated formula but as
fairly as we can we're going to give
your state this much of this federal tax
money back he said if you applied the
highway formula to these bills you would
find a completely different allocation
of resources people would basically what
he found was about 70 senators would
gain from changing this bill and 30 25
30 would would lose he said anytime I
have 70 votes on my side I think I can
win this so he takes it to the floor
puts an amendment on the floor all
happened very quickly as to put the
Neman together quickly he's got pressure
from the leadership dole is calling him
the mottoes calling him you better get
that bill on the floor we're going to
move this don't you hold this up now you
know that sort of thing means a very
antagonistic process calls for the vote
meanwhile Lautenberg D'Amato bird are
all lobbying ferociously telling other
members don't go with Smith on this if
you go with Smith on this bill you'll
get nothing from us again which is
always the ultimate threat of the
appropriators if you cross us you get
nothing the next time you want something
and you'll always want something you
know that's their theory of the mutual
they call it the balance of terror up
there if you want something you can
forget about getting it from us if you
oppose us on this Smith makes his pitch
they had some embarrassing moments in
there turned out there was some pork
slipped into the bill that Smith didn't
know anything about Warren Rudman had
put it in the great crusader for a
balanced budget Warren Rudman had
slipped his own pork into the bill it
was very embarrassing to Smith they
mentioned this on the floor and he was
caught unawares Lautenberg gives a
ringing defense meanwhile they're
lobbying hard in the cloakroom clerk
calls the role bills defeated 84 to 16
stunning defeat absolutely
incomprehensible 70 people would have
lost money on this bill yet they voted
with
operators will go back to the front
cover it says how washed and waste your
money and why they won't stop the way
you're describing it it'll never stop
them there is room for pessimism
certainly but I think there's also a
possibility of some optimism it will
stop if people send representatives to
Congress whose primary job is not to
bring home a bag full of goodies whose
primary job is to deal with the huge
national problems that we're facing a
deficit budget that is bleeding red ink
at the three to four hundred billion
dollar-a-year rate figuring out I mean
obviously pork is not the only issue
here entitlements the whole world of
mandatory spending Medicare Medicaid
Social Security how do we wrestle with
that if you can't deal with the pork
which is purely luxury luxuries you
certainly can't deal with the other
question how much pork is there in a 1.2
trillion dollar budget 100 billion
dollars I say in this the current budget
we're operating fiscal 92 there's a
hundred billion dollars worth of what I
call pork in there and then obviously
none of it is needed I would say that's
not needed no I think you could cut it
all out people will probably argue maybe
you could cut 70 billion out other
people will make the case you could cut
a hundred and fifty billion out but I
think 100 is a reasonable number you
could cut it out it wouldn't affect the
lifestyles of anybody maybe there'd be
some discomfort here or there but you
know pork it's a it's a huge category
people think of it as the small projects
I've been a Lawrence Welk Museum these
petty things that Proxmire used to make
fun of in the Golden Fleece but the
mentality that gets you the Lawrence
Welk Museum you know gets you the 700
million dollar toilet seat in the
Philadelphia Naval Shipyard it gets you
the five or six billion dollar buffalo
subway system it gets you incredible
amounts of defense pork is the
Washington DC subway system 10 billion
dollar system pork I think you probably
have to argue that it is or its pork of
another era it's
it's complicated because there's so many
jurisdictions at play here there's an
argument that the federal government you
know may have an obligation to bring its
own workers to work i mean the District
of Columbia has particular particular
differences that that might mitigate
some of the money that's been spent here
but you had a classic case just this
year Barbara Mikulski the senator from
Maryland was also is it on the
Appropriations Committee and ended up
getting the government to spend more
money than it then the Washington subway
system had asked for they're putting an
extension of the subway into Maryland
and and the subway system was asking for
a bus substantial federal handout
Mikulski basically gave him about thirty
percent more than they wanted I mean
that was pure pork barrelling she's a
pre-election this year though that's
what that was all about page 55 want to
read this paragraph one astonishing
statistic was revealed recently in a
study by economist James Payne for his
book the culture of spending he added up
witnesses who testified for and against
increased spending at an assortment of
congressional hearings over the last
several years and found that among 1060
Witnesses on subjects as diverse as farm
credits housing and job training only
seven people spoke against spending more
money against spending less money I'm
sorry I'm sorry frankly seven people
against against spending more money out
of a thousand sixty witnesses exactly
and is that the way I mean that's a
thousand Americans or probably Americans
testifying only seven out of a thousand
i am told in that that was interesting
because it was a very hard data and he's
a reputable political scientist who
studied this but i am told anecdotally
from other from members of the
committee's up there that that's about
right virtually no one comes to capitol
hill and says don't spend money everyone
comes to capitol hill and recently
there's this new sensitivity so they all
say well of course i know we have this
terrible budget situation i know where
virtually bankrupt and we're bleeding
red ink
we really do have to cut back except for
this project which is you know crucial
to national security or the fate of the
nation or you know whatever the issue is
and that's if you're going to give a
little pass to some of these cars from
that's what they hear all day they here
all day from people who want something
spend spend spend whether it's the
farmers the veterans the construction
industry back home you know they don't
hear from another myth of pork of course
they're not hearing from the average
voter they're not hearing from their
general constituents back in their
district they're hearing from particular
constituents they're hearing from people
with a vested interest in the particular
spending project how would you grade the
news media on covering pork ah I think
the media is gotten a little better
about being aware of it I think in this
election they've done a pretty good job
of holding Clinton's and bushes feet to
the fire about spending issues about
always raising the question Bush
promised XYZ but said had no idea how is
going to be paid for Clinton program
says this but has no idea of where the
money is going to come from I think
that's really important what about back
there in those hometown newspaper
hometown television I think the hometown
newspapers and I have not conducted a
thorough survey but certainly in my
experience the projects that I looked at
in some detail the hometown newspapers
are boosters there they they function
and they are part of the problem there's
no question about it it pork is a way of
keeping score and they will tweak their
local congressman when he doesn't bring
something back is a number of cases in
there that I talked about steamtown
Railroad Museum in Scranton one of the
great pork barrelling boondoggles of
Walt on the local Scranton paper is an
absolute booster of it you know they run
editorial saying you know sometimes
they'll take a cynical approach and as
they do in Scranton they say well the
government's wasting all this money
anyway why should we get our share of
the waste steamtown will cost how much
when it's all over a hundred to a
hundred and fifty million dollars
congressman responsible Joe McDade from
Scranton currently under indictment
right
not for Steamtown but for some other
related things how is this Republican
congressman able to get all this pork
for a museum or a park or what would you
how would you describe I would describe
it as an amusement park I suppose it's a
it's to be the Federal Railroad Museum
it's actually a working railroad they've
got the Park Service in there they
bought track they've restored miles of
miles of track in the in the mountains
there in Pennsylvania they've restored
bridges they've they've built the rail
yard from scratch that wouldn't much to
really restore their there was no reason
to have it there in the first place but
if you bend this yeah I've been there I
visited visited the site it's a it's
amazing to look at it and to contemplate
where this money could have gone they
may very well have put it in a bonfire
in the center of the art and lit it and
you have to pay to get in it no it's
it's free it's federal park service
federal park the National Park Service
want this um they didn't they
essentially the Park Service has a
process by which they decide where
they're going to put their money and
this was simply written into an
appropriations bill that they were going
to do this so they were they were forced
to do this by macdade and so they didn't
want this steam town USA development in
the National Park Service right and now
they're going to get a hundred and seven
million dollars to in order to do this
to the people of Scranton want it well
it's interesting I I there are people
there who think it's good i'm sure the
newspaper that the town father's such as
they are are great boosters of this
they're the people who stand the most to
gain i suppose by it i did a radio show
just the other day from Scranton and was
was amazed I was really expecting a lot
of opposition because I'm very very
critical of steam down in the book and
I've written about it elsewhere I was
amazed at all the calls were supportive
of me they were all saying you're right
this really awful you know and i think
that's that's one of things that gives
me hope that I think people are a lot
smarter than I think the politicians
give them credit for um if it is
explained to them how this works if it
is explained to them that this is not
free money that they are paying for this
in many ways and they they are right
there in Scranton they can see that this
thing is an absolute boondoggle I think
they will draw the logical conclusion
they seem to in scranton what's the
point the problem of course is who's
going to turn down you know I hand out
who's going to say as long as the
government is building it you know it's
at least creating some construction jobs
it's at least doing something so if it's
plopped in your lap you know human
nature would suggest know you're
probably not going to say let's rip this
whole thing up and send the money back
to Washington I want to be careful
because I know that an indictment is not
conviction and because I'm gonna mention
another name of another congressman from
that part of the world Dan flood who was
convicted 13 counts right what right
basically influence-peddling against
this was in the early 70s was just
related to his ability to get pork to
the state of Pennsylvania was similar
flood was one of the champion pork
barrel errs people remember him he used
to wear the snidely whiplash mustache
and he would have have capes in a top
hat and he give these long theatrical
speeches on the floor of Congress he was
a little bit south of
scranton/wilkes-barre and was one of the
great pork barrel errs his pork project
was his most famous one was the forcing
the Pentagon to buy anthracite coal
anthracite coal is mined right in there
and the wilkes-barre/scranton area
depending on to this day must buy tons
of anthracite coal ship it to Germany to
heat the barracks of the US forces
stationed there even though it would be
both cleaner and cheaper to use oil
purchased in Europe to do this every
year in the defense appropriations bill
is the memorial Dan flood clause which
says the Pentagon must buy anthracite
coal to heat these bases McDaid is
carried on that grand tradition
presidential port you got a chapter
called hog wallow but what's that what's
the purpose of that title well hog
wallow was the year end what I followed
was a year in the life of pork I started
with the end of the budget deal of 1990
and the little hat you know that my
first simple question was how did the
Lawrence Welk Museum get in there how
does a project like that get into the
federal budget at a time when were in
such dire straits and I follow the
spending process from from that the
beginning of the year from January of 91
through into the fall and hog why don't
you were doing by the way that during
that period was that full-time well I
was still working at regard ease as well
I was editing the magazine but spending
did you go up on Capitol Hill a lot
right I was probably you know every day
I was up on Capitol Hill one hearing or
another and Riaan things like conference
meeting when I could get in yeah I mean
it's not always the easiest thing some
of them were deliberately closed I was
thrown out of a few of them who through
yeah the staff aides physically ejected
told no close close to the press this is
when the house and the Senate conferees
come together to decide what bill is
going to go back to the house and the
Senate right final boat right and and
how often are those open in the
appropriations process uh I don't know
the statistics on those it's it was you
know just sort of my random survey it
seemed like about him more than half of
them were closed they were very why
would they close them why should they
close the arguments are I guess if it's
if that there was a defense spending
bill they felt that there was some
national security concerns I suppose it
was never explained to me in any detail
what why this was it was just the
tradition these were not open sandy or
something I don't affords the other the
other problem is some of them are are
formally closed others are effectively
closed because they're held in small
rooms where they there might maybe one
member of the press might catan do you
ever see a television camera in a
conference never know oh they're
certainly all close to the to the
broadcast medium and can you bring an
item of pork as you call it into a
conference report if it's not already
there coming from you to the house of
the Senate side in the process sure sure
anything can go into a conference bill
and then often does that's often when
the you know this hand capitol hill is
never over till it's over bill passes on
the floor of the house and it may it may
not bear a resemblance to what emerges
from the conference committee just to
press vigorously try to get into
conference up on the hill on when they
want to you know there's the specialized
press on Capitol Hill the congressional
quarterly folks and some of the
newsletter people and they they will
they will be in there
mana cleanness often the general media
is if there's a particular bill they're
interested in they'll try to get in
sometimes succeed sometimes not but
there's there's not there's not a lot of
attention focused on these issues unless
it's a very hot bill who talked to you
you say a lot of people wouldn't talk to
you was there anybody that would talk to
you during the year Congress people well
I I was I ended up following closely the
the there is a group that called
themselves the pork Busters and this was
Bob Smith and Harris very well from
Illinois principally that put together a
bill that was intended to strip some of
this stuff out they were very good about
you know allowing me to watch that whole
process and what does that work together
those who were putting the pork in the
bills wouldn't talk to put it in no I
mean the best the best interview I had
was I talked to a number of former
congressman who were a little more
candid Tony Coelho who was a master at
pork barrelling self-admitted master of
pork barrelling he said he used to teach
pork barrelling to the Democratic
Congressional Campaign Committee young
members having some problems he said I
take him into him a lecture about how to
do this qual o is one of those you know
very articulate a realistic hard-nosed
politician I have a certain admiration
for people like that as you said within
the case of bird as well he's very
unabashed about it he said it's part of
the process if you take pork out of the
process you're taking politics out of
the process the pork is about trying to
reconcile all these competing interests
in an imperfect system and I think
there's some you know there's certainly
something to that argument is the points
of light foundation of pork barrel
project and what is it the points of
light foundation will emerge from George
Bush's speech the convention speech in
1988 and this was his whole pitch toward
volunteerism and he set up a even though
that was a clearly a campaign initiative
he set up a with government money a
Foundation which he called the points of
light foundation which is staffed with
friends of his I guess it's one of these
presidential patronage back waters
but the idea was that they were supposed
to coordinate the volunteer efforts in
in Washington and like a lot of little
pieces of pork and special patronage
that the president gets this is up for
review by the appropriators and it was
just kind of funny the way they would
tweak Bush about it they at first they
cut the house cut it out completely and
then they couple of the senator said
well we've got to give the president his
do and let's put a little bit back in
and they they kind of went back and
forth a little bit on this just as a way
of making fun of him because of course
Bush was giving these angry speeches
about the pork barrelling the Congress
was doing pounding the table saying this
this this has got to stop I've got to
have the line-item veto but the reality
was he was putting his own pork in there
at the same time he had his own several
several of his own pet projects so much
bigger than the points of light
foundation and was also not doing
anything really effectively or
substantively to try to stop Congress he
was only talking about it is the 23
million dollars it spent on the National
performing arts center named after john
f kennedy pork barrel stuff i would
argue it that it is i think the whole
world of culture spending is a is an
area where you you've got to make some
real hard calls about how much the
government ought to be supporting things
like the arts you know you can get the
classic conservative argument which is
absolutely not at all you know you
should you should be spending anything
on that I think you can probably argue
that there's some role for the
government to promote culture to support
forms of national culture I mean we have
a Smithsonian Institution we have a
national you know a national attic of of
historic relics why shouldn't we have
something that's that's a little more
contemporary but I think that when you
look at the scale of the Kennedy Center
how much money is being spent on it that
the sort of some of the productions that
go through there that bear no real
really know their commercial Broadway
productions they bear no relation to to
sort of preserving any kind
any kind of national culture you could
argue that a lot of it is unnecessary
which raises an interesting point
there's no science and saying what sport
what's not pork chat what I think has to
happen is you've just got to sort of
take a more common sense approach to a
lot of these projects and say ultimately
is this something we can really afford
at a time when what this is all borrowed
money I mean it's they don't all of this
is going to the bank to borrow money so
you know if you had all the money in the
world the budget weren't surplus maybe
the Kennedy Center makes sense if you're
bankrupt you know if you're if you look
at your own checkbook you know if your
if your if your checkbooks in the red is
that the time to go buy season tickets
to the Baltimore Orioles what about the
1 billion dollars over the next three
years for the corporation for public
broadcasting again I that's a certainly
a hardline conservative argument that
would say absolutely not you know George
will made that case that everyone said
oh well we've got we're gonna we're
going to lose big bird here it's not
pork in the classic sense and that you
don't have it's not a specific
constituency you don't have a
congressman or a small group of
congressmen bringing this home to their
voters but is it necessary spending is
it something the federal government
ought to be doing I think there's a real
serious question it's probably not again
we only have a few minutes left and that
I've said this a couple times but what
will it really take to stop the port I
mean and when do you think it's possible
when at what point in this process that
we've been watching over the last couple
years will some of these things stop now
I am encouraged that it may stop fairly
soon I think you see some significant
votes in Congress this year already you
had a hundred and forty members voting
against the Congress's own legislative
appropriations bill which is Congress's
personal pork two and a half 2.8 billion
dollar corporation 140 members said
that's excessive you've got 100-plus new
members coming in this year a lot of
these are people who have been energized
by the Perot voters energized by the the
notion of change by we've got to stop
doing business as usual
you start to add 100 members on to 140
and you you know what we're talking
about a majority here I think the change
is going to have to come from the house
principally the Senate is much bigger
porkers than they were ever supposed to
be and I think they're going to be
slower to change I think as we've seen
from both the White House and Clinton
this is not a subject either one of them
wants to address seriously but I have a
great optimism that the house is the
place that that we can see substantial
change and I think we can see it this
year are you at all surprised about the
reaction of the people you've been
talking to about your book I'm pleased
by it I have to say I mean I've gotten
letters from lobbyists and other members
and people who said you know if this is
I never really appreciated this problem
for what it was because as I say you
know the the myth in Washington is that
pork is petty and what I say is pork and
the pork mentality is very significant
and if we don't if we can't deal with it
we're never going to deal with any of
the other problems that we're facing so
you know here it is here's the case
here's what pork is here's why it's
hurting us and here's why we can do
without it let's see if somebody's going
to do something about it do you plan any
follow-up book on this issue or is this
it for Brian Kelly and the pork no I
would I am hoping I mean will i'd like
to see what what happens with this one
first but i think that there is a
another book to be done that maybe
broadens this topic even more and looks
at the question of entitlements and the
question of other spending you know more
specifically beyond pork how we deal
with how we deal with these spending
questions because i do i believe that it
is the issue of the 90s we have we have
you know as a journalist I think that's
where the great story is going to be in
in sorting out some of these budget
questions and how this country spends
its money's is is really the whole ball
game by the way whose idea was it to get
pet often to do the illustration Pat's a
friend and we were having lunch one day
and I was telling what I was working on
his eyes kind of lit up he's he's got an
evil streak to him and he said oh boy I
could have a lot of fun with those guys
so we went ahead with it this is the
cover adventures in Portland the author
Brian Kelly our guest thank you very
much thank you fine